Hello everybody.
My name is Michele with one L.
This is my talk "It takes a village to make
a programmer".
It's a talk in 2 parts.
The first part is my story and the second
part is a bunch of suggestions for you, for
how you can help in your own village.
To start my story...
I went to school for teaching and I unfortunately
graduated at the height of the recession in
the United States.
So I ended up not getting a teaching job and
I was just substitute teaching, which I think
is the most demoralizing job in the world.
I was really unhappy for awhile.
I realized I would have to move to get a job
and I thought: if I'm going to move away for
a job, I'm going to move far, far away.
After 2 years of substitute teaching, I moved
to Germany.
When I got here, I got a random office job
that wasn't going to be permanent.
I realized I had a big decision to make.
There were lots of different directions my
professional career could go.
I had thrown around the idea of maybe becoming
a UX designer.
I could teach English as a foreign language.
I could try to go back to teaching.
I could keep this office job if I really wanted
to.
Or I could do something totally different.
So, one day at my office job -- I was an office
manager for a tour operator for people who
went on cruises -- we got a bill from our
programmers.
The bill was really outrageous.
It was for this really simple customer feedback
form that we asked them to create for us.
I had written back and forth to them about
10 times with all these little things that
they could have done to make it better.
I was taking German courses at the time and
afterwards I had gone out with my classmates.
I was so angry and so upset about this, I
was raving to them about how I could do it
better...
I should be a programmer...
I could do this...
I didn't take myself very seriously, but one
of my classmates did.
She emailed me about a course that was going
to be offered in Berlin called "Front-end
web development for beginners".
It was really expensive, so I sent an email
to my brother saying "Hey, there's this course.
Wanna sponsor me?
LOL"
I got the loving response from him of: nothing.
I wrote to him a second time, "No, seriously.
What do you think?
Will you help me out?"
He said yes, so I took the course.
Halfway through the course, one of the people
working for General Assembly -- the company
where I took it -- was also running a group
here in Berlin called "Berlin Geekettes".
I found out they were offering a hackathon.
So after 6 weeks with just knowledge of HTML
and CSS, I participated in my first hackathon.
This was where I had my "Holy.
Shit."
moment.
I was like, "Oh my god!"
The energy that you could feel in the room,
when everybody was just getting together and
hashing out their ideas and forming teams
and working together...
The energy was electric.
I looked around and I just saw amazing things
happening.
People were taking ideas that just existed
inside of their own head, and using nothing
but their computer and their hands and people
around them they were taking this idea and
making it into something that other people
could do and use and interact with.
I thought that was amazing.
I thought: I want to do that and I want to
do that and I want to do that.
I want to be able to do everything.
I ended up quitting my office job.
I finally realized what I wanted to do.
And I thought, OK I am going to do it.
Berlin is the city where you can take some
time off and afford it, so I decided to do
this.
I had a lot of free time on my hands once
I was unemployed and I heard about a conference
called Eurocamp.
It's a Ruby conference that happens here in
Berlin.
I'd never heard about anything like a tech
conference before.
It was never something really on my radar.
I thought, cool, an event where everybody
is interested in the same thing and they go
there and hang out?
I want to go!
A couple of people I knew had gotten tickets
through Rails Girls.
They'd gotten them for free through a diversity
outreach program.
But there were no tickets left.
I couldn't afford go myself, being unemployed.
They said "follow the Twitter account and
maybe somebody will sell theirs for free,
or get rid of it for a cheap price!"
I started following the account and I saw
this guy, Bruno and he tweeted: So, I have
my Eurocamp ticket and unfortunately I can't
go.
Let's make it count.
Give me a good reason and it's free.
#givesomethingback
I tweeted at him right away and I wasn't sure
if I could get the ticket -- I didn't know
what other people I was competing with and
what reasons they had -- but I said: I'm really
passionate, please give me a chance.
And I did get the ticket.
I got the ticket with several stipulations.
He said: OK, you can have the ticket, but
I have three rules.
Number 1: You have to have fun.
You have to have a lot of fun.
I said I can do that.
Number 2: Find my friend Justine, she is giving
a talk, give her a hug.
I said I can do that, too.
Number 3: I don't care what you do, what it
is.
Somehow you need to give back to the community.
I said: OK, I can do that.
So that's part of what I'm here doing today:
hoping that I can inspire you to give back
to your communities as well.
I went to the conference and it was way more
impactful in my life than I ever could have
imagined.
It was where I took my first Rails Girls workshop
and I decided I did not want to start programming
by learning Rails.
One of the girls I attended with went on to
become one of my best friends.
I was exposed to the idea of lightning talks
for the first time and that was the first
time I thought to myself: maybe I can be a
speaker too.
Five minutes?
I can do that!
Probably the most important thing was this
talk that was given at the Rails Girls workshop
by another woman who had changed careers one
year after her first Rails Girls workshop.
I don't remember a single thing about her
talk, because I just sat there the whole time
after she had been introduced, thinking to
myself: I'm going to do that, and I'm going
to do it faster and I'm going to do it better.
Since then, she has actually seen me give
this talk and we have spoken about it.
She is cool with it, because you want your
talk to impact people and how effective is
your talk if you don't even have to give it
for it to have such a profound inspiration?
So, I attended this wonderful conference and
was back to my unemployed life.
I had 5 really good days.
5 great days where I was working from the
moment I woke up until a reasonable hour in
the evening.
Keeping track of what I was doing, how much
time I spent learning each thing...
It was really productive first week.
After that everything went downhill.
I don't know how much you have tried to do
completely on your own, but it is not easy.
After that it became a big struggle.
Luckily at the same time I met another guy,
named Franks, who also quit his job.
We had these really symbiotic interests, where
he was interested in learning more about teaching,
I was interested in learning more about programming
and those were both our respective careers,
so we teamed up.
He became a real huge mentor for me.
He would hang out with me and pair program.
He would whip up a gist and explain a concept
if I was getting trouble getting it and we
weren't together.
He wrote homework assignments for me.
He really pushed my learning forward and helped
me to have somebody to rely on.
Somebody I could trust and ask questions and
help me improve and expand my knowledge.
Soon after this -- because relying on Franks
wouldn't have been enough -- I found about
a program that was being piloted in Berlin
called Hackership.
It's based on the Hackerschool in New York,
if you're familiar with that.
It is a full time learning program for programmers
of all levels of experience.
Basically, what you do is come together full
time and just working on learning whatever
you are interested in.
Not only do you have mentors provided for
you, but you're working alongside other people,
so it's like a real academic setting.
It helps you have somewhere to go and you
get to put on workshops yourself.
One of the best parts was, at the end of every
week we had to give presentations to the whole
group, so I got to practice my public speaking
and got to share what I was working on during
these six weeks, which was a web application
that I was building in Ruby without any frameworks
or any libraries except for the crypto stuff.
The thing I was most proud of was the user
authentication system I wrote.
That was really cool.
That was for 6 weeks and that really pushed
my learning forward.
Just to recap on the timeline of the situation....
January 22, 2013 -- last year -- that was
when I wrote my first "Hello world" at this
front-end web development course.
And January 21st of this year -- 2014 -- I
got not one, but two junior developer job
offers.
Once I finally got over the fear of looking
for a job.
(applause)
So, some really exciting news.
I work for Sociomantic.
The team I started on was doing the CSS for
ad banners.
So I have been doing CSS exclusively for the
last six months, but I just found out this
week I got accepted to a new team where I
will be doing native JavaScript.
(applause)
I got this job offer and I accepted it but
because of some legal issues I had to wait
about a month-and-a-half before I could start
working.
Again I had some more free time, so I decided
to apply to speak at my first conferences.
I got accepted to speak at my first conference.
It was another Ruby conference in Uruguay.
Uruguay is pretty far away from Berlin.
Something happens when you are unemployed
for seven months.
You run out of money.
So I got accepted to speak at this conference,
I was invited to go, but I had no way to get
there.
At the urging of the conference organizers,
I setup an Indiegogo and again the community
overwhelmed me with their support.
In 24 hours I made all the money I needed
to cover the flight and somewhere to stay.
Just out of the generosity of people's hearts.
Most people didn't know me at all.
They just read the little description of this
talk I'm giving now.
I have to thank a couple of people as one
of the rewards.
Thank you to Bruno, Denis, Dafydd, Seth, Sven,
along with a dozen other people who helped
me to get there.
(applause)
So thank you to them.
As I have said, the community has done so
much for me and so much to help me to get
to where I am today, that now I would like
to give you some suggestions for how you can
help in your own community.
I'm going to go through a list of suggestions
with some different resources, based on what
resources you have.
I hope there is something for everybody here.
This is how to help in your own village.
If you have a little bit of time, just a little
bit, there are still things you can do.
The first thing is, you can give encouragement.
It's such a simple thing, but it can have
such a huge impact.
I can't tell you how many days I was learning
programming and I would get stuck on a concept.
It would not click in my head and I'd think:
What are you doing?
Are you crazy?
You should go back to doing something else
because you're never going to figure this
out.
It's never going to work out.
And then, inevitably, living in an international
city like Berlin I would meet somebody and
they would say: what are you doing in Berlin?
And I'd be like: oh, I'm changing careers,
I'm learning how to program.
And they'be like: no way, that is so awesome!
I'd be like, oh... yeah, it kind of is awesome,
I'm following my dreams!
It would just jolt me back.
I have a real reason I'm doing this and I
do belong in programming.
Something simple as "hey, that's really cool"
can really make somebody's day.
Something else you can do with a little bit
of time is expose your passions.
I want you to take to Twitter, take to a blog,
a meetup, start speaking about whatever you're
interested in.
Everybody in this room has something they're
interested in that is unique, but you don't
know who else shares this unique interest
of yours if you don't talk about it and you
don't share it.
Especially consider ways you can be inviting,
to talk people who might not have as much
knowledge about this as you do.
Think of ways to get other people involved.
If you have a little bit of time or a lot
of time, there are some options for you...
Quality beginner-friendly resources.
There are 2 parts to this.
The first is, just sharing them.
If you only have a little bit of time you
can find quality resources and share them
by tweeting them or just telling people about
them.
Or if you have even more time, maybe you can
write some yourself.
Because as you know, there is such a wealth
of resources out there and they are not all
created equal.
You can Google how to do something and find
25 different blog articles and you know that
some of these are crap and some are good.
But you don't know, if you are inexperienced.
If you have any sort of motivation to write
some of these things, please do it.
Maybe you don't have time, but you have money?
You can be a sponsor.
It is so easy to have so many excuses why
you don't want to try something new or get
into a new field or get started.
You can talk people out of a lot of excuses,
but you can't talk someone out of not having
enough money.
You could sponsor someone for a course or
workshop -- like my brother did for me -- or
some other creative way to use the resources
that you have.
You can also send somebody to a conference.
As we said before a conference is so much
more than just talks and professional development.
There is networking, you meet friends, there
can be workshops.
You just get so much more from a conference
than you can imagine.
It can be a really great place, but as you
know, they can be really expensive.
If you have some way to get an extra ticket
or if you're an organizer: JSConf did a really
great job with these diversity tickets where
you could buy one and send someone else with
it.
Something like that is really awesome.
If you have a lot of time, you should become
a mentor.
This is the single most important thing that
you can do for anyone who is starting out
or changing careers.
It is the biggest thing you can do to help
someone.
If you have somebody to trust and somebody
you can ask these questions to and you can
share your experiences with.
There are so many different ways you can do
this.
It doesn't have to mean just one thing.
You could meet for lunch as often as monthly,
or weekly.
Whatever you can commit to.
You could pair program with people.
You could simply offer advice by email.
In the last year, I found out about this program
called mentoring.is.
It is a distributed mentoring movement.
You add /mentoring to your personal website,
and they give you a text that you can use
to just say to people, "Hey, I'm open to being
a mentor.
This is how to get in touch with me."
It is a really great way if you don't know
how to get started or how to get involved
in your community.
You can simply add this and start sharing
it.
If you have space and time.
There are more options.
We need you to create safe spaces.
What do I mean by that?
Safe spaces can be anything: a hackathon,
a workshop, a study group.
It could mean a women-only group.
Or some sort of minority-only group.
I want to make a point about this.
There seems to be some controversy, where
people think that these whatever-only spaces
are exclusive.
They're not.
They're actually inclusive.
They include people who otherwise would have
been excluded.
Whether they would have felt uncomfortable,
or unsafe or couldn't get in due to overcrowding.
Whatever reason it is, it includes more people
who otherwise wouldn't have been included.
Why are safe spaces important?
They are really important because this is
where you challenge yourself and take risks
and stretch your limits.
You can't find out what new things you can
do if you don't feel comfortable enough to
try new things.
That's why safe spaces are so important...
for us to have these community spaces.
Finally, if you have courage, I urge you to
tell your story.
Especially if you have a story that doesn't
fit the mold of the stereotypical kid who
started programming when he could write and
has been doing it his entire life.
I have a quote for you from a documentary
called Misrepresentation.
It says: you cannot be what you cannot see.
Of course there are exceptions.
But if you can be a role model or a hero for
somebody...
where they can identify with something in
you, and if you are a little bit different
than other people, that can be a really amazing
way to help out by just becoming a figure
for people.
So, what now?
I'd like to take one moment to give a shout-out
to hard work and to acknowledge the hard work
that I did put in.
And that other people like me have put in.
Because even with all the help in the world
it wouldn't have been possible, and I think
it is important to acknowledge.
I also have one more quote for you.
It is by Tal Ben-Shahar, who is a positive
psychologist from Harvard.
He says: there is so much benefit to the person
who contributes to others that I often think
that there is no more selfish act than a generous
act.
So that means anything you do for other people,
you're really doing for yourself.
Any of these ways that you can help out, you
will feel a reward.
And it will feel good.
I can promise you that.
So, now I would like you to please return
to your villages and make some programmers!
(applause)
Thank you.
I have some resources for you.
I will tweet it out later.
It has different things.
What I used to learn programming, mentoring
and diversity groups, if you are interested
in learning how to diversify more in your
own company.
And some different coding groups for kids.
Again I would like to say thank you to everybody
who has helped me, thank you for listening.
Thank you from the future for all the people
that you will help.
Thank you for the people that you have been
helping.
Thank you for everyone you have helped already.
Thanks.